it was immediately obvious that the
attack on a russian air base in crimea
was a big one
thick clouds of smoke could be seen from
miles away and the explosions sent
russian tourists heading for cover
i went out to look at the window and it
was as if a mushroom cloud from a
nuclear explosion had risen there there
were two big explosions like that
everything began to fall around and
collapse crimea is deep in russian
occupied territory the kremlin has been
using the air base to launch attacks on
ukraine
russia said the explosions were just an
accident on the base and the ukrainians
are yet to officially acknowledge their
involvement but a senior official here
has told us that it was ukrainian
special forces who carried out the
attack
it is a big coup for kiev and it will be
deeply uncomfortable for moscow
the russian side must be feeling quite
nervous at this point that they're not
making good progress that ukraine keeps
fighting as effectively as they do and
striking back against an important air
base and doing so in an area in form of
crimea that's so important to russia
crimea was illegally annexed by russia
in 2014.
the saki air base that was attacked
yesterday is on the peninsula's west
coast more than 150 miles behind russian
front lines
satellite imagery taken yesterday before
the attacks shows at least 30 russian
aircraft on the tarmac ukrainian sources
say that nine fighter jets were
destroyed and others damaged
one person was killed
we cannot verify precise figures though
only one out of the 14 injured are
hospitalized the rest are at home thank
god they all have light injuries the
main task now is the repair of
infrastructure we have 62 multi-story
buildings damaged
overnight russian forces hit back
shelling apartment blocks a school and a
concert hall in the dinipro region at
least 13 civilians were killed
today videos posted on social media
showed long queues of cars trying to
leave crimea the reality of a brutal war
that most russians have been shielded
from came too close to home alistair
bunker sky news in ukraine